as you mentioned China playing that
bigger role as a global Peacemaker Saudi
Arabia and Iran agreeing to resume
flights between the two countries and
facilitate visas for Citizens while it
follows a meeting between Saudi and
Iranian foreign ministers in Beijing for
the first time in seven years or part of
a Chinese mediated deal to re-establish
relations after years of tensions to
harana Riyadh now working to reactivate
trade deals and reopen embassies so Rob
have they taken further steps to take
their relationship to another level
yeah this all builds upon this Landmark
agreement that was brokered by China
between these Regional Rivals the first
official meeting between two foreign
ministers in seven years and they have
announced a a number of different
arrangements and agreements moving
forward to develop and normalize these
ties they have issued a joint statement
saying that embassies and consulates
will be reopened flights will be
re-established and also that they will
facilitate the exchange of visas to
allow visits to take place especially
between visits of officials as they seem
to normalize relations once more thanks
so much Rob we'll leave it there for now